- It's possible that Marvel
might lose the rights
to some of its most popular
characters: Spider-Man,
Black Widow, Thor, and
Iron Man, among others.
It's possible they might be
ripped right out of the MCU,
because copyright is weird.
But Marvel is being proactive.
That's why they're going
to court to stop the heirs
of the creators of some of
its most iconic characters
from getting any royalties.
With these lawsuits, Marvel is arguing
that characters created
by geniuses like Stan Lee
are ineligible for copyright termination
because they were works made for hire.
In other words, since Lee
was a Marvel employee,
his estate is not entitled
to any of the profits
from future TV, movies, and merchandise.
And Marvel makes the same
argument against Steve Ditko,
Gene Colan, and Larry
Lieber, or their estates.
Ditko, of course, is the reclusive legend
who created Spider-Man with Stan Lee.
Colan is the genius behind Daredevil,
Falcon, Carol Danvers as Mrs. Marvel,
and the cult satire Howard the Duck.
Lieber drew newspaper strips
of "The Incredible Hulk"
and "The Amazing Spider-Man"
and was instrumental in creating Iron Man.
Marvel is still making movies
and TV shows featuring these characters,
and they are a big part of
Disney's long-term plan.
Well, maybe not Howard the
Duck, at least not yet,
but if that dog killer Cruella de Vil
can get a favorable origin story,
we know that Howard the Duck
probably can't be too far behind.
- That's it.
No more Mr. Nice Duck.
- But this is no small matter.
If Marvel loses these lawsuits,
its parent company Disney
would have to share ownership
of these characters that are
worth billions of dollars.
(stately music)
Hey, Legal Eagles, it's time
to think like a copyright lawyer.
So let's talk about why is
Marvel suing the creators
of some of its most famous
characters and what's at stake.
Let's take a look at what prompted Marvel
to file these lawsuits.
Steve Ditko was a
renowned comic book artist
who collaborated with Stan Lee
to create Spider-Man and Doctor Strange.
And unlike Lee, Ditko was a recluse
who preferred to live in privacy,
much like author J. D. Salinger.
In his post-Marvel career,
Ditko invented cult
favorites like Squirrel Girl
and wrote several comics
featuring objectivist characters
modeled on the philosophy of Ayn Rand.
Ditko lived and worked
alone in a Manhattan studio
until his death at the age of 90 in 2018.
And no one knows what Ditko
worked on in his last years,
but his last published words came in 2019.
Quote: "Here's to those who wish me well,
and those that don't can go to hell."
And in this case, those who can go to hell
might include Marvel and Disney.
- Oh, dear, what an awkward situation.
- Now, this isn't always
the case, but sometimes,
there are termination provisions
under copyright law where
authors or their heirs
can reclaim rights once
granted to publishers
after waiting a statutorily
set period of time.
Ditko's heirs, in this case,
include his brother and his nephew.
In August, his estate filed a notice
of termination on Spider-Man.
The Ditko termination notice demands
that Marvel must relinquish Ditko's rights
in Spider-Man by June of 2023,
and there are termination provisions
potentially at issue with a whole host
of some of Marvel's
most famous characters.
So just what is a termination
provision in US copyright law?
Well, copyright termination
is the termination
of a grant or transfer of
someone's copyright rights,
and the Copyright Act of 1976
lengthened the term of
copyright protection,
giving copyright owners even more time
to control and profit
from their works of art.
This was the major policy accomplishment
of congressman Sonny Bono,
otherwise known as 1/2 of Sonny & Cher.
Yes, he did go on from the duo
to hold office in Congress.
And many people have either
blamed or congratulated Disney
on this extension of the copyright term.
But note that not all copyright holders
are the original creators of the art.
For example, Paul McCartney co-wrote
some of the most memorable
songs ever written,
but over the years, he's sold or lost
the copyright to that material.
Most of the Beatles'
catalog is currently owned
by Sony/ATV, which
acquired a good chunk of it
from the estate of Michael Jackson,
who famously purchased
them for $47 million.
♪ Yeah, yeah, ooh, ooh, yeah ♪
In 2018, McCartney filed
termination notices
to reclaim those Beatles copyrights.
Eventually, he settled with Sony/ATV.
A decision on the merits of that case
would have been a landmark ruling,
but both sides obviously felt
there was too much to risk to proceed.
And with the value of the
Beatles publishing rights
over $1 billion, there's
plenty of money to go around.
Now, creators can lose or
voluntarily assign rights
in a number of different
ways, including just entering
into a contract that
seemed fair at the time,
but in retrospect turned
out to be very one-sided.
Now, the amended Copyright Act
therefore gave some artists
the chance to get their copyrights back,
provided that they lost their rights
on or before January 1st, 1978.
So the idea was that Congress
is extending the copyright term,
so if you had a copyright
and then transferred it
to somebody else before
1978, then you were allowed
to claw back that copyright assignment
or transfer many decades later,
and now a lot of those
terms are coming due.
Following termination, any rights
transferred under the grant come back
to the person who created
the copyrighted work.
The purpose of this provision
is to let authors, musicians,
and illustrators and other
artists renegotiate the terms
of their original contractual agreements.
It basically gives artists a second chance
to get a better deal.
If the author is living,
like Larry Lieber,
they can file a termination
notice at the appropriate time.
Lieber is Stan Lee's little brother.
He's responsible for co-creating
Ant-Man, Thor, and Iron Man.
Marvel is suing Lieber to stop him
from terminating the Marvel copyrights
to these characters, or in other words,
Marvel is going to court to
say that in this situation,
the termination provisions don't apply
and the rights therefore don't
have to go anywhere else.
But not all rights return
after a successful termination.
Creators' American rights
revert, but foreign rights,
which are usually negotiated separately,
do not return to the creator.
Derivative works created under
the authority of the grant
before its termination can
continue to be exploited,
and as you can see, this
is a more complex situation
than it first appears.
So let's dive into the Copyright
Act provisions at stake:
17 U.S.C. 203 and 304.
The first question that arises
is which works are
eligible for termination.
Although most grants of copyright
rights can be terminated,
some grants are excluded.
Since the termination provisions are meant
to give the author a second chance,
if the author is still living
and the original grants
were made by somebody else,
these grants can't be terminated.
If the author is living, grants made
by anyone other than
certain statutory heirs
are also ineligible for termination.
The list of individuals is
included in section 304.
And the act also excludes
grants made by will,
so if an author died 50 years ago
and granted their copyrights
to someone by will,
that person's heirs can't attempt
to revoke the grant under this section.
Additionally, and this is the big one,
the Copyright Act's termination provisions
do not apply to works made for hire.
A work made for hire has
a complicated definition,
but generally speaking, if you're employed
when you make something
that could be copyrighted,
it's your employer who gets
the copyright to that thing.
It's not the employee who made that thing
while being employed by somebody else.
And if a work is made for hire,
an employer is considered the author,
even if the employee
actually created the work.
The employer can be a firm,
an organization, or an individual.
This is a very contentious part of the law
for comic book creators,
many of whom were actually employees
when they created their characters.
And determining whether
something is a work for hire
is challenging and depends on the facts
of each particular situation.
Now, there are some complications
in when the termination
notice needs to be provided.
I won't bore you with the details,
but it generally has to fall
within a five-year termination period,
and here, the Marvel cases
mostly involve grants
executed before January 1st, 1978.
And in addition to the timing,
there are tons of procedural
issues, like co-ownership.
A majority of the co-owners have to agree.
There are lots and lots
of procedural issues here
that are extremely
boring and have no place
in a 15-minute YouTube video.
And other creators have filed
termination notices as well.
They tend to be represented
by attorney Marc Toberoff,
the lawyer who represented
"Superman" creators Jerry Siegel
and Joe Schuster in their
ultimately unsuccessful
termination attempt against DC Comics.
Now, under some circumstances,
a would-be defendant can go into court
and get the court to adjudicate the issue
before everything goes crazy,
and that's what Marvel has done here.
Marvel has filed suit
against the creators,
alleging that they were all employees
and that the works that they created
were considered works for hire
and thus not subject to
copyright termination.
Marvel is asking federal
courts in New York
and California to issue
declaratory judgments
blocking the termination
notices and affirming
that Disney is the sole
owner of these characters.
So you might see headlines that
Disney is suing the owners,
and it sounds nefarious,
but there's really nothing wrong with it.
They're adjudicating this case early,
and while Disney would
normally be the defendant
in an action like this,
they're really just going to the court
to adjudicate exactly the
same things that they would
if the creators were the
ones that were suing Disney.
Now, a lot of this
litigation is going to turn
on the definition of a work made for hire.
That's defined by section
101 of the Copyright Act,
which defines a work made
for hire in two parts.
It can be either A, a work
prepared by an employee
within the scope of his
or her employment, or B,
a work specially ordered
or commissioned for use
as a contribution to a collective work,
as part of a motion picture
or other audiovisual work,
as a translation, as a supplementary work,
as a compilation, as
an instructional text,
as a test, as an answer
material for a test,
or as an atlas if the
parties expressly agree
in a written instrument signed by them
that the work shall be
considered a work made for hire.
And the Supreme Court has
interpreted a work for hire
in the famous case of CCNV vs. Reid.
Now, in that case, the Community
for Creative Non-Violence
made an oral agreement with
James Reid, a sculptor,
to produce a statue depicting
the plight of the homeless
for display in a 1985
Washington DC Christmas pageant.
After the sculpture was
completed and delivered,
CCNV paid Reid in full.
Shortly after that, both
parties filed separate
and competing copyright
claims over the sculpture.
A lower court held
that the sculpture was
a work made for hire,
and after the Second Circuit
reversed the decision,
it went all the way to the Supreme Court.
And the Supreme Court ruled
for Reid, the sculptor,
holding that the court
must first ascertain
whether the work was
prepared by an employee
or an independent contractor.
If an employee created the work,
part one of the definition
that we talked about applies,
and the work will generally be considered
a work made for hire because it was made
within the scope of that
person's employment.
But this gets more complicated,
because the term employee
in the definition
differs from the common
understanding of the term.
For purposes of the
Copyright Act, an employee
means an employee under the
general common law of agency.
If an independent
contractor created the work,
then the work was specially
ordered or commissioned.
Part two of the definition applies.
And an independent contractor is someone
who was not an employee
under the general common law of agency.
And the Supreme Court created four factors
to determine whether
someone is an employee
under purposes of the Copyright Act.
I won't bore you with those definitions,
but you can actually
read it in CCNV vs. Reid.
It's actually a pretty
understandable court decision,
as those things go.
But in this litigation,
it will probably focus
on what's called the
Marvel Method, which is a,
quote, "loose collaborative
working atmosphere
where initial ideas were briefly discussed
with artists responsible for
taking care of the details."
Marvel characterizes this
as a traditional
employer-employee relationship,
and Marvel argues that any contributions
that Steve Ditko, for example, made
were at Marvel's instance and expense.
Marvel editorial staff have the right
to exercise creative control
over Steve Ditko's contributions,
and Marvel paid Steve
Ditko a per-page rate
for his contributions.
When Steve Ditko worked for Marvel,
he did so with the expectation
that Marvel would pay him.
Moreover, Marvel says that its
editorial staff had the right
to exercise creative control
over Steve Ditko's contributions.
Quote: "Any contributions Steve Ditko made
to the Works were done at Marvel's expense
because Marvel paid Steve Ditko
a per-page rate for his contributions,
Steve Ditko made those
contributions to the Works
with the expectation that
Marvel would pay him,
and Steve Ditko did not
obtain any ownership interest
in or to his contributions."
And Marvel made the same arguments
in the other lawsuits as well,
and the representatives
of the comic book creators
will make the same legal
arguments that Jack Kirby did
over a decade ago when Kirby
and Marvel litigated the issue
of whether Kirby could
terminate a copyright grant
on "Spider-Man," "X-Men,"
"The Incredible Hulk,"
and "Mighty Thor."
In 2013, the Second
Circuit Court of Appeals
affirmed a lower court ruling
that Kirby's heirs could not terminate
the copyright over those characters,
since Kirby had contributed his materials
as a work made for hire.
Kirby tried to appeal
to the Supreme Court,
arguing that he was
essentially a freelancer,
not an employee.
Kirby didn't receive any
benefits or fixed salary,
nor did Marvel reimburse
him for his expenses.
Kirby also worked from home,
and although this would seem
to suggest that he was an
independent contractor,
the Second Circuit saw
the situation differently.
Quote: "Despite the absence
of a formal employment agreement,
however, the record suggests
that Kirby and Marvel
were closely affiliated
during the relevant time period.
Lee assigned Kirby, whom he
considered his best artist,
a steady stream of work
during that period,
and Kirby seems to have
done most of his work
with Marvel projects in mind."
The Second Circuit emphasized
that the key factor is
whether a work is made
at the hiring party's
instance and expense,
and that happens when the employer
induces the creation of the work
and has the right to direct and supervise
the manner in which the
work is carried out.
The Second Circuit
acknowledged that Kirby's,
quote, "working relationship with Marvel
between the years of 1958 and 1963
was close and continuous,"
and continued, quote,
"Understood as products of
the overarching relationship,
Kirby's works during this period
were hardly self-directed projects
in which he hoped Marvel,
as one of several potential publishers,
might have an interest.
Rather, he created the relevant works
pursuant to Marvel's assignment
or with Marvel specifically in mind.
Kirby's ongoing partnership with Marvel,
however unbalanced and
under-remunerative to the artist,
is therefore what induced
Kirby's creation of the works."
It's believed that Kirby
had a looser agreement
with Marvel than many other
artists, including Lee.
And when the Supreme Court
declined to accept the appeal
from the Kirby case, the parties settled.
And since the ruling only applied
to two of Kirby's four children,
the others lived in California,
Marvel opted to settle
with the family rather
than face more litigation.
So this probably means
that Marvel has the edge
because of this published
Second Circuit ruling.
In the current cases,
Marvel argues that the
Kirby case is dispositive
and that the courts
must rule in its favor.
However, the ultimate issue
of whether the Marvel Method
of producing comics means that
the creators were employees
still hasn't been decided
by the Supreme Court.
And one of the most important factors
in determining whether you are an employee
or an independent contractor
is whether your employer provides you
with the tools you need for the job,
and if your employer doesn't
give you a cell phone,
you can save a ton of money
on your cell phone bill
with today's sponsor, Ting Mobile.
In fact, I personally
switched to Ting Mobile
and saved literally
hundreds of dollars a month.
I'm not kidding about that.
Why? Well, because of this.
Yes, this is a real cell phone bill
that I got with my previous provider,
and that's why I personally
switched to Ting.
And Ting Mobile has three brand-new plans
to make sure that that
never happens again.
All of Ting's plans have
unlimited talk and text
starting at just $10 per month,
so you can use the Flex plan
and only pay for what you use,
which is especially great if
you're around Wi-Fi all day.
You can choose a set of 12
gigabyte of data for $35
or get full unlimited for $45 a month.
Switching plans is actually really easy
because you can keep
your same phone number
and use pretty much any phone.
And the service is great too,
because Ting partners with
several massive networks,
probably the very same one
that you're using right now,
but at a huge discount.
They literally use the
same infrastructure.
Now, I actually can't tell you which ones
because I always respect contract,
but let's just say that my
service hasn't changed at all,
and you get the benefit of
other massive networks as well.
And if you're around Wi-Fi all the time,
like you're working from home,
you have the flexibility to
save hundreds of dollars a year.
That's because Ting still
gives you the option
to just pay for what you
use with their Flex plan.
Now, they give you the possibility
of unlimited versions as well,
so if you want unlimited,
you can go absolutely crazy.
And it's incredibly easy
to transfer service.
All you have to do is just
order a Ting SIM card,
pop it in, and set it up.
No phone calls are required.
It's like magic.
But if you do wanna talk to
Ting, you can call them up
and immediately talk
to a real human being,
or you can talk to them
on chat or Discord.
You'll talk to real human
beings, not AI robots.
Virtually no wait times,
because they don't have
brick-and-mortar stores.
They pour it all into
their customer service.
Now, if you'd like to give Ting a try,
Legal Eagles will get a
free $25 service credit
that could cover two months of service.
All you have to do is click
on the link below and give it a try.
You can even use your last bill
to compare just how much you would save.
All you have to do is click on the link
that's onscreen right now.
Plus, clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
And while you're there,
check out this playlist
with all of my other Real Law Reviews
on the most important
legal issues of the day.
So click on this playlist,
or I'll see you in court.